what is the worst gift you've ever
received and who gave it to you
they gave me a bucket of fried chicken
and then they drew an afro on like
Colonel Sanders and then they put Khalid
fried chicken and I colored it in I ate
it but hi I'm Cal DS for the shocking
questions hey what's up guys I'm Khalid
and these are the shocking answer what
is the most embarrassing thing you've
ever done to win someone's heart when I
was in like second grade or whatever we
were like walking around the track and
there was just that girl that I kind of
like ones to win her over so I like
lifted up my shirt and like I was the
heavier child so I like made my stomach
talk and I was sick all right who was
more fun to collaborate with Billy
Eilish
or Shawn Mendes my max power yeah who is
hotter you or me me did you know I'm
totally fine with that answer because I
just didn't want to press the button
what is your biggest fashion mistake I
have a couple I definitely wore one
outfit on Twitter and got flags and that
was it I don't even want to think about
it gives me like PTSD I hope the video
actually find this oh it wasn't
definitely I didn't know either yeah
yeah I know pine what is your favorite
artist of all time
oh but answerable Frank Ocean is the
greatest artists alive right now okay
Heyman's is the lyrics when you like the
size of the legs come on
who is the most overrated celebrity in
the entire world no come on they're
gonna I didn't write these questions
this isn't fair at all what is your most
most disgusting habit no what is the
most embarrassing thing you've ever done
most embarrassing thing I've done I mean
we all pick our wedgies every now and
then right I'm not a frequent wedgie
picker they're very discreet I've kind
of like mastered the art of like you
know just like a quick take it like no
one knows
that's impressive I feel like that to
kawaman I think 1.5 seconds what is the
biggest age gap you would still go on a
date with which artist would you most
want to perform with pink pink I think
she has the greatest performances I mean
maybe she could put me like on one of
those like trapeze isn't like hang me in
the air and stuff anyway
what is your sexiest feature my smile
who is the person you're most proud to
have as a follower on social media Halle
Berry followed me not too long ago I
thought that was crazy she's awesome so
shallots out of the bay
I've never contacted her though because
it's easy to notice yeah right This Is
It this is the final question the last
one please just all I ask is that you
answer it
what is the worst gift you've ever
received and who gave it to you oh yes
okay there was this promoter in
Australia who gave me a bucket of fried
they gave me a bucket of fried chicken
and then they drew an afro on like
Colonel Sanders and then they put Khalid
fried chicken and I colored it in and I
ate it but I was like mad at myself for
like a class so good boy hate this [ __ ]
it was horrible and a little racist I
never have it we managed to get through
all of the questions I think I did a
good run yeah there was definitely some
minimal shocks awesome